let's sneak in another political story
today's democratic primary in
massachusetts is getting nationwide
intention
in part because of one famous name on
the ballot that would be congressman joe
kennedy
joe kennedy iii he's trying to unseat
senator ed markey and the most recent
poll showed that marky
is in the lead but it's close ed o'keefe
is covering campaign 2020 for us ed good
morning to you what's in the line what's
on the line rather
in this senate race well in one way tony
family history because never before in
massachusetts as a member of the kennedy
family lost a political campaign
whoever wins tonight is expected to
easily win the senate seat in november
but this has quickly become one of the
nastiest political races
of the year usually when a kennedy runs
for office in massachusetts their
victory is all but assured
but not this year congressman joe
kennedy's challenging senator ed markey
in what's become a bitterly
personal contest you just didn't deserve
justice
39 year old a grandson of the late
robert f kennedy
believes the 74 year old senator isn't
doing enough to represent the state
he missed over 50 percent of the votes
in this critical time of covert 19 a
public health and economic catastrophe
kennedy only recently started playing up
his family legacy
it's a fight in his blood and mostly
he's questioning marky's record on civil
rights and votes for things
like the iraq war marky who's been in
politics for more than 40 years
has gone back to the future talking up
his decades of service and introducing
the liberal green new deal
with one of his most prominent
supporters new york congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez ed markey
is a proud and and strong progressive
champion for working families
markey's also doing something once
considered unthinkable by a
massachusetts democrat
he's taking swings at the kennedy legacy
we asked what we could do for our
country
we went out we did it with all due
respect
it's time to start asking what your
country can do
for you still kennedy's supporters have
confidence in his abilities
and every time they come to a new
kennedy comes to office
something happens there's some reason
something happens something changes
but markey is seeing strong support from
younger voters
ed markey has proved time and time again
that he
is always forward thinking and is
a progressive that we all deserve and
need in
the senate so nearly one million people
have already cast ballots in this race a
sign
of the big interest and given the
pandemic we'll see how long
it takes to count the absentee ballots
want to reinforce the family history
here again
the kennedy family in massachusetts has
gone perfect score
26 wins zero losses in democratic
primaries so
big pressure on joe kennedy tonight to
deliver if he loses
there's still a chance that a member of
the extended family will be serving in
congress next year
that's because democrat amy kennedy
who's the wife of joe kennedy's father's
cousin patrick if you follow that yeah
he's running for an open seat in new
jersey anthony
thanks very curious to see how this one
turns out